it's the first official visit by an
independent Human Rights expert
Clement fillet the UN Special Rapporteur
spent 10 days in Zimbabwe human rights
workers say dozens of activists have
been abducted there since January there
is this kind of general fear if you
don't belong to this party you are with
this party and this polarization and the
lack of trust the lap of also political
dialogue is something that also have
impacts on the enjoyment of the rights
of freedom of association peaceful
assembly in many of my discussion with
victims of the excessive use of force by
police there was victim related that
they were targeted because they belong
to opposition party the most recent
alleged abduction was a union leader dr.
Peter McComb a four days health workers
marched demanding to know where they
colleague was he was later found alive
government officials deny abducting
citizens the police is keen to apprehend
the alleged abductors so as to bring
them to justice and protect the public
fool a also raised concerns about the
role of the army and police in dealing
with demonstrations against the
government during violence after
elections last year at least six people
protesting over the disputed results
were shot dead by soldiers no one was
arrested in January several were killed
when security forces broke up a
demonstration of a rising prices event
in August police violently broke up an
anti-government protest organized by the
main opposition party movement for
Democratic Change several people were
injured the hope many Zimbabweans had of
a more open society and better economy
when president msi minagawa took over
from Robert Mugabe has turned into
disillusion Zimbabwe's economy is in
trouble millions of people here are
struggling with soaring inflation and
high unemployment but often those who've
led protests have disappeared or been
arrested that's why some here say
keeping quiet
you say a final report by the UN due to
be released mixture will give
recommendations to the government how to
better protect citizens rights but some
people here say they've heard these
words before and nothing's changed
Hodder Matassa al-jazeera Harare